let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
well it is Wednesday afternoon
93 o'clock Central
here I am here you are
today this morning Magneto
and Loki we're trending on Twitter
[Music]
completely different reasons
I'm probably gonna get into that today
but Magneto and Loki were both trending
today superheroes superhero Powers I
consider my superhero power to be the
word [ __ ] that is my super hero
ability
superhuman [ __ ] over here
so we're going to talk about this magnet
sticking Fork spoons Keys
5G Q Anon Maga [ __ ] today we're
gonna talk about that
because it's all over the Internet this
uh supposed doctor in Ohio
uh this is standing in front of a
microphone puking up absolute garbage
about the vaccine uh the same the same
type of garbage that they were picking
up about the the virus itself so we're
going to talk about that we're also
going to talk about Rudy giuliani's
little tape phone call that he had with
uh the ukrainians
and we're going to talk a little bit
about Hunter bite and that's going to
lead us into Hunter Biden's laptop and
uh hashtag racist Hunter I guess Hunter
biter Hunter Biden supposedly typed out
the n-word so we're gonna talk a little
bit about that and then I also want to
touch a little bit on the vice president
of the United the actual Vice President
of the United States Kamala Harris
taking a trip down to Guatemala to
actually
fix the problem that they've been
yelling and screaming about since 2016.
instead of going and having a little
photo op in front of the wall so we're
going to talk about that a little bit
and and I mean where do you want to
start where shall we start with all this
nonsense because that's all this all
this stuff is just [ __ ] straight
noise all of it every [ __ ] last bit
of it is goddamn fake outrage and fake
noise
[ __ ] that's all it is
like for instance this Magneto thing so
Loki obviously Loki is apparently uh
released on Disney plus and everyone's
going to enjoy Loki but then we see
another superhero emerge from the
Twitter universe Magneto because some
supposed doctor now we can't even trust
the word doctor anymore you got Rand
Paul claims to be a doctor he doesn't
know a [ __ ] thing
in a [ __ ] bonehead we had this lady I
don't even know what her name is it
doesn't really matter
but they let her stand in front of a
microphone inside of a Ohio legislator
committee room
as if she had some significance at all
because she has a podcast let me tell
you something if having a podcast gets
you in front of a legislator by God I
got a microphone
and she starts talking about how people
are sticking she sees videos and photos
on the internet number one right there
that's enough all right turn the mic off
you know and we don't need to hear any
more from this bonehead
when you say the phrase there's pictures
people see pictures on the internet
those interwebs
they see those and they believes them
they believe them some facts because it
was a picture on the internet
[ __ ] we have failed big time
we have [ __ ] failed in critical
thinking skills this person stands there
and says that people are
magnetized somehow with getting a shot
in your arm as if I I'm not sure exactly
how this [ __ ] works I don't know if
there's something in the shot that makes
your blood magnetic I I'm not real sure
what kind of [ __ ]
crazy ass science fiction story that
they've read somewhere else that they're
getting mixed up with real life
I'm not I don't [ __ ] know and then
somehow it has something to do with 5G
interface and the cell phone towers and
God damn
I mean we can't even have a rational
conversation anymore about anything
with these Q Anon Maga types
this cute on stuff has taken over these
people critical thinking skills and
maybe they didn't have them in the first
place maybe that's the real [ __ ]
problem here
and I was talking to my my mom this
morning some of you know my mom some of
you have heard my mom on Tick Tock lives
and you know that I get my yelling and
screaming from her
and I told her this morning I think I
said I think it's your generation that
is [ __ ] this whole thing up
I don't know what happened I don't know
what the [ __ ] happened everyone blames
Millennials for everything
but it is the generation above
Millennials before Millennials that is
just lost their goddamn Minds with this
Q Anon stuff
they are off the [ __ ] rails with this
nonsense this magnetized and computer
chip and 5G and all kinds of craziness
and even me talking about how crazy this
is
and saying these buzzwords on YouTube
they're probably gonna [ __ ] cut this
podcast off because they're gonna be
like well this guy's saying some stupid
[ __ ] about the vaccine so we gotta turn
his [ __ ] thing off
I'm just repeating what the [ __ ] they're
saying
and saying how [ __ ] dumb it is
here's the thing people
she said there's pictures of people with
keys and spoons and forks attached to
their bodies
that's what she said
number one
everyone knows the [ __ ] lick the
spoon trick who the [ __ ] does not know
that trick
I mean have you never been [ __ ] 10
before Jesus [ __ ] Christ
and then you go to keys
keys are made out of brass
which brass is made with zinc and iron
which are not magnetic
so when you make a key out of brass it's
not magnetic even if you were Magneto
and you had some superhuman power to to
get
magnetic power
it it wouldn't work with car keys
it wouldn't [ __ ] work
because it's not magnetic
just bone-headed [ __ ] boneheaded [ __ ]
and then and then to top it all off with
this Q Anon science stuff
we have Louie Gomer this this morning
ah
it's it I can't even you can't even make
this [ __ ] up like it's
you can't even make this [ __ ] up
it's it's that [ __ ] stupid
he tells
the Bureau of Land Management and Forest
Service or you ask them he asked them
if they can go ahead and work on getting
the planet and moon to realign in their
orbit so that we can fix climate I'm not
[ __ ] [ __ ] you this I'm I'm not
this this is a thing
I'm not making this up it sounds like it
but I'm not making this up he actually
asked
the forest service if they could figure
out a way to change the orbit of our
planet and the moon to fix climate
change
holy actual [ __ ] this person is an
elected official he isn't he is actually
in charge of something
of representing somebody
this is who
a certain amount of Texans
want to be talking for them
this is where we're at
because we find out also from a poll
which
I don't know if we can trust these polls
on this stuff
but apparently three out of ten
Republicans believe that Donald Trump
will reassend in August
that's right somehow he's going to I
don't know take back the presidency or
something and this
we are way off the deep end with these Q
Anon folks
they're out there they and half of them
don't even realize that some of this
stuff is queuing on they they don't
really realize it they're regurgitating
it from social media they're watching
Newsmax they're watching oam they're
watching Tucker Carlson they're
listening to all this [ __ ] stupid
garbage Mike Lindell and and and [ __ ]
Mike Flynn and Linwood and Sydney Powell
and going to these Q Anon Gatherings
these seances these Nazi rallies
completely out of their goddamn cult
Minds
folks that's where we're at it's a
goddamn cult
cult cult
so of course
of course
I'm
I'm a I made a Magneto tick tock
oh [ __ ] emran of course uh because I I
saw that that this needed attention I
think someone even brought it to my
attention on Twitter said hey a video
would be good for this one
and I couldn't resist couldn't resist
the old Magneto science
angle of this so let me let me play My
Tick Tock you guys have probably already
seen this but let me play it and then
we'll we'll come back on the other side
and talk
apparently these Q Anon Maga Trump
humping Evangelical Christians think
that the vaccine makes you Magneto what
the [ __ ] oh because they seen a picture
on the internet of someone sticking
their car keys to their [ __ ] forehead
I guess it shouldn't be a surprise that
they don't know that keys are made of
brass and Brass isn't magnetic you dumb
[ __ ] Ed try out one of your Louis Gomer
science experiments grab that magnet off
your refrigerator you [ __ ] idiot tire
at it why don't we change the orbit of
the planets and the Sun you know with
your thoughts and prayers that sciency
type [ __ ] you can write a letter to that
space laser loser dick and she could
conjure up some help on the subject
[ __ ] bobert buffoon she could really
give it a pew pew America this
delusional Q Anon [ __ ] is an
anti-science anymore it's anti-critical
thinking dumb [ __ ] I like to call it
more head up ass syndrome you know any
old cranial dysfunction [ __ ] them
any old cranial dysfunction because they
straight have their heads all the way up
their [ __ ] asses
when you think car keys and and are
magnetic
and you think that the the vaccine is
making you Magneto and somehow you're
going to connect to cell phone towers
and you you think that the forest
service can somehow come up with a plan
on how to readjust the Earth's orbit
are there's [ __ ] space lasers
we are in a deep deep hole with these
[ __ ] idiots the problem is not that
we have idiots we've always had morons
in this country there's always been
morons and they've always believed
stupid dumb [ __ ]
always
we've had them forever we will always
have them
and I believe it's about 10 to 12
percent of the country are the [ __ ]
boneheads
the problem right now that we have is
that they've all gathered in one God
damn spot like they're not they're not
all over the map like they normally are
you know they're all they're they're
usually all over the map here
but they're all gathered up in magaland
queuing on land
all gathered up in one goddamn spot
and and they just can't help themselves
and that's the problem that we have
so
I don't know what the actual uh solution
here is uh to help people figure out
that
all this is all a bunch of [ __ ] just
like all the [ __ ] last year that you
heard about the virus that was untrue
that was all a bunch of [ __ ]
you boneheads Mast worked they didn't
give you bacteria that killed you the
Mast actually worked it prevented like
droplets coming out of your your mouth
and that would stop from other people
getting sick it worked pretty good the
whole social distancing thing worked
not being indoors with each other it
[ __ ] worked
it all worked
you said it didn't and now you're saying
now you're saying that the vaccine makes
you Magneto which really honestly
it didn't sound that [ __ ] bad does it
I mean if the vaccine's gonna give us
super powers
I mean I'm hoping for like Wolverine
type [ __ ] yeah that's you that's who I
want that's the powers that I want not
Magneto [ __ ] Magneto
[ __ ] Magneto I want I want Wolverine
so maybe maybe if I ever have to have a
third dose
maybe I can go for the Wolverine dose I
don't know
so let's
let's move on from the Q Anon lunacy and
let's talk about this Rudy Giuliani
phone call
uh the I think this is very significant
it's very important and I think there's
a lot of people [ __ ] themselves
this is a new development now the the
knowing that this call happened is not
the thing that we learned because if you
watched it all
the fortune the first impeachment
testimony when they were impeaching him
in the House of Representatives uh for a
quid pro quo with Ukraine the quid pro
quo was hey I will give you the aid that
we said we will give you if you act like
you are going to investigate my
political opponent and damage him
politically for my election so I can get
reelected
that was the quid pro quo
and in the testimony we heard
several witnesses
in particular voker is say Rudy Giuliani
was making phone calls and talking to
ukrainians with a quid pro quo at the
direction of the president of the United
States at the time which was Donald
Trump
we've had testimony that that was what
happened
and then yesterday we found out that
that's exactly what happened there was a
tape that was released of Rudy Giuliani
talking to the representative that was
representing the president of Ukraine
and pressuring him
to say in public the thing that they
that thing that they testified that they
impeached him for
to say in public that there was an
active investigation and they were going
to investigate corruption with Biden
whatever corruption they could find
basically if you listen to the tape
number one Rudy Giuliani is a [ __ ]
slob he's talking to the representatives
for president of Ukraine and he's easy
it sounds like he's eating a [ __ ]
baloney sandwich or something oh what
the [ __ ] are you kidding me
you couldn't take 15 minutes not to
stuff your face you fat [ __ ]
good Lord
he must have been in a hurry to get on
to the next corruption call I don't I
don't know I'm just surmising here
but he clearly he clearly pressures if
you listen to the tapes he clearly
pressures
the Ukraine government
to not only investigate something that
he knows doesn't exist
but he clearly pressures them to
announce it in public
he says clearly if he will say it out
loud in public we just might get him to
be able to meet the president of the
United States Donald Trump
that's a really nice Aid package you got
there it would be a shame if something
happened to it
what he was saying
this is a mobster type [ __ ] what the the
best part about the whole thing is of
course Rudy's gonna deny all this and
say that's not what I said that's not
what I said I I that's totally illegal
that's total that's that's gonna be the
[ __ ] that's totally legal it's totally
legal and it's totally legal it's
totally legal you're gonna hear that
phrase a lot totally legal
once you know before he never said that
He never [ __ ] said that but now that
we know he said it and there's tape that
he said it and he knows that we know
that he knows that we said it that he
said it and it's on tape
what he's gonna do is say well
and what I said
is totally legal
that's what we're gonna keep hearing
from the Maga universe
is that it was totally legal what he did
again because as long as it's totally
legal it's totally ethical right I mean
in that in that what we're supposed to
believe
in that what they'll have us believe as
long as long as there's no law
preventing it by God it's ethical
and not only is it ethical Republicans
should do it but if Democrats dare do it
or anyone else dare do it you better
[ __ ] watch out and you you better be
prepared
just like just like when we get some
[ __ ] story from the Daily Mail which
is probably all [ __ ] and it's I mean
it may be real it may not be but who
gives a [ __ ]
apparently there's screenshots of a
hunter Biden text message that has the
n-word on it
rather it's true or not I guess they'll
track it down eventually
so Hunter Biden types out the n-word
and all of a sudden all of a sudden the
racist in this country who don't wanna
who do not want to who do not want to
teach critical race Theory
they do not want racism taught to their
kids because it doesn't exist
they do not they do not they do not want
you to challenge them on systemic racism
rather it's through the voting John
Lewis Voting Rights Act HR one now it's
S1 or the George Floyd policing act they
do not want you to challenge them on
racism there because it doesn't exist
but
but
when someone like Hunter Biden might
type out the n-word
wow obviously racism exists
because you know
[ __ ]
this is this is this is the the
dumb [ __ ] they don't even know what
they believe anymore this is why I think
we're in good shape here
we're in good shape for 2022.
what's gonna be their platform Hunter
Biden's laptop that's really what
they're gonna go with
that's how they think they're going to
win the house and the Senate back as
Hunter Biden's laptop that's where
they're going to end up
Because by the time we get to August and
they have to move the goal post again to
win their [ __ ] orange Mussolini Jesus
is going to be reinstated
[ __ ] most a lot of people are gonna stop
believing that garbage and they don't
really believe this stuff they don't
really believe this garbage they don't
do it that's like they they they've said
for four decades that they believe they
believe that uh fetus is a is a human
being they don't believe that [ __ ]
they don't
and there's a handful of them but they
generally don't believe that garbage
they just don't want women to have the
right to do what they want with their
bodies
because [ __ ] that we've heard my body my
choice my body my choice about the mask
and the vaccine and on and on and on
and now now that now that you do have
the choice to get the vaccine or not
somehow it's oppression well you have
the choice you could get the vaccine or
you can't get the vaccine
you had the choice not to go to a
concert not to go to a football game and
if you do you got to get tested you got
to wear a mask I don't know what to tell
you that's how it seems like it's gonna
be
you're probably gonna have to choose
whether you go to college or not you're
probably gonna have to choose whether
your kids are in public school or not
I'm sure that'll be a choice that you
will have to eventually make
choices
you know my body my choice right
but when it comes when it comes to
abortion ah no no
now
so when they can't have their orange
Mussolini Jesus
reinstated by the time they get to next
summer which that's when this will all
heat up we'll know who the candidates
are on both sides and in particular the
Senate races are going to be the
probably the the most salacious
um there's a lot of
knucklehead Republican Q Anon magatites
out there running uh for Senate and I'm
sure some of them will capture some of
these nominations let's hope they do
I hope they capture those nominations
that is going to be key to winning the
Senate overwhelmingly and then once we
win the Senate overwhelmingly
we can tell Kristen Cinema and we can
tell Joe manchin to shut the [ __ ] up
we're changing the filibuster they can
be happy that they weren't the ones who
destroyed it because that's all they
want folks they don't they don't really
give a [ __ ] about that filibuster they
don't care about [ __ ] Joe manchin and
Christian Cinema if if it really was
about principle here they would go on
the principle that one person one vote
the people get the vote the people get
to the side not you [ __ ]
Kristen Cinema is on the border with
John cornyn talking about flip you know
uh it's the the government's swinging
back and forth
it wouldn't swing back and forth
it won't swing back and forth if you
give people access to the ballot
and you let the government
govern like the majority wants them to
govern
it won't swing back and forth if you
stop gerrymandering districts if you
stop trying to cheat to win if you stop
trying to suppress the vote
it won't swing back and forth
the the majority will govern
and that's what they don't want
they don't want the majority to govern
that's what this is that's what Trump
was
when you all go Christians who claim to
have the moral ground
they [ __ ] elected a three-time
three-time married with kids with three
goddamn wives
and and
divorced from two of them with the next
person that he was married to
because she got pregnant he has to pay
off porn stars
this is who they elected to be their
moral leader
and they think somehow he's their
Shepherd you know we're the Sheep right
Liberals are the Sheep
give me a [ __ ] break
no there aren't liberals out there
running around with Joe Biden flags on
their boats and their trucks and got
their truck their Biden hats and their I
see a Freudian slip
Biden doesn't have hats
Biden doesn't have shirts Biden doesn't
have Flags you see that do you see that
do you see how that works
and he and
three out of ten Republicans that's the
poll 3 out of ten Republicans think that
this guy is going to be somehow
reassended the presidency and sometime
in August
so let's let's break that down a bit
three out of ten Republicans let's say
let's say at this point
that 40 45 of the country and I don't
even think it's that high would
self-identify as Republicans at this
point because I think a lot of them are
like [ __ ] that I am not a republican
those people are nuts they're [ __ ]
crazy
but let's say let's say let's give let's
give him 45 so we're talking 30 of that
45 percent
that's what we're talking
are living in a deluded reality where
Donald Trump's going to reassend to the
presidency
because Hunter Biden's laptop and I
don't know fake ballots in Arizona and
Audits and
who the [ __ ] can tell and now we got the
magnet lady
these are the same people the same p and
here's what they want
they want
to be fooled
that's what they want
they want to be fooled they want to be
fooled they want to be fooled
they want to be lied to they want to
hear what they want to hear it doesn't
matter
if it's a lie if it's the truth they
don't give a [ __ ]
because they believe this stuff
regardless if someone says it or not
rather trump perpetuates it or Q Anon
perpetuates it or it's on social media
or wherever they already believe this
[ __ ] this 3 out of 10 Republicans they
already believe this stuff
they already believe it
they already got it in their [ __ ]
thick skulls at this thing gonna happen
they don't care if someone says it or
not
they already believe it they just they
just want it verified so Donald Trump
gave them per permission to have someone
in charge of something that will verify
what they [ __ ] believe
the nonsense I mean Jesus Christ we
watch Kamala Harris the vice president
of the United States go down to
Guatemala
she was going to meet with the
government in Guatemala to see if she
could fix the migrant problem
people from their country coming to our
country which they and I say they I mean
Maga
Maga q and on Trump humpers
they've been yelling and screaming about
this problem since 2015 2016. yelling
and screaming Mexico is going to buy I
mean even Marsha Blackburn today was
saying Biden should build the wall
Kamala Harris the vice president of our
country goes to Guatemala
to
try to work with the Guatemalan
government
to see if there is a way
that those migrants can stay in their
country those migrants are looking for
things like food
jobs and safety that's what they're
looking for
food jobs and safety
that's what they're looking for and
they're coming here to to do it
now
to have them at the border and detention
centers and with our immigrations laws
the way they are which are completely
[ __ ] up
but we can't even Jesus Christ we can't
even agree on voting rights how the hell
are we going to agree on immigration
reform for [ __ ] sake at this point
2022 cannot get here soon enough I guess
to try to work with the Guatemalan
government she goes to try to make sure
that they can keep their migrants in
their country so they're not coming here
and trying to get them through the
process legally and safely if they need
Asylum as opposed to
having coyotes bring them to the Border
humanitarian thing
like that's the lens that they're
looking through which
a government like the United States
should look through this as a
humanitarian issue
and
Kabula Harris didn't go do a photo op in
front of the border wall how dare you
how dare you go fix the [ __ ] problem
how dare you go to Guatemala and try to
make sure that those migrants don't come
here that's what we wanna we wanna [ __ ]
about that
what are we gonna [ __ ] about if you if
you get the Guatemalan government to
participate with you to try to make sure
those migrants don't come across our
border where
convinced the knuckle Dragon white
people that we need a wall how are we
gonna do that if you go down there and
fix the problem what you should do is
you should go to the Border take a nice
picture in front of the wall take a nice
picture in front of the Detention Center
and then fly back to Washington like
Republicans do for crying out loud
that's how you perpetuate a problem and
you try to win elections Jesus Christ
you act like this is this is about
policy and trying to make the country
better
what are you what are you dumb this is
about winning elections
that's that's the message that's the
[ __ ] message
that's what they're saying when they're
saying that stuff
because let's face it
think about it
if Kamala Harris would have got on the
plane instead of going to Guam well she
would have went down to a detention
center and took a photo op in front of
the border wall in front of a Detention
Center
they would have said oh my God she can't
even go where the problem is can't even
go to Guatemala you can't even go there
and try to negotiate what are you scared
what are you scared
how dare she just do a photo op she
thinks photo ops that's what they would
say
it doesn't matter what Kamala Harris
does it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
what the United States government does
it doesn't matter what Joe Biden does it
doesn't [ __ ] matter it doesn't matter
it doesn't even matter what Guatemala
does it doesn't matter
they are going to [ __ ] about it
they are gonna find a way that they are
against it
because at this point they have no
belief system they have no core
principle there's no core principle for
immigration anymore it's just build
a wall
build a wall that's that's our core
principle that's all we want and
we kind of wanted Mexico to pay for it
but now we're kind of rethinking that
and we want the United States government
to probably pay for it well what we mean
by that is we want to take money out of
the pockets of the United States
military to build the wall
that's what we want
but build the wall
but there's no substance none and the
reason why there's no substance is
because there is no substance between
the ears
that's why they're so mad they're so mad
that Kamala Harris went to Guatemala
is because she's trying to fix the
problem that they want to [ __ ] about
which the problem is a humanitarian
problem because then you have the other
side of the coin these people are coming
here and taking our jobs they're coming
and taking our jobs can't you see it
these immigrants these brown people come
in here and taking our jobs
all the all the while all the while
bitching bitching that no one wants to
work I can't even get someone to work at
McDonald's I can't even get someone to
work at this place or that place to
serve my needs
well these people want to come here to
work
so maybe they'll go do those jobs that
you are so pissed off that you can't go
into a McDonald's and get a cheeseburger
in less than five seconds
maybe they'll come here and work there
you know make a living pay taxes maybe
buy a house eventually participate in
the economy nope
nope
it's always two things at once with
these [ __ ] because they don't
even know what they believe anymore they
have no [ __ ] idea no clue no [ __ ]
clue which by the way by the way the
whole job labor we don't have people are
lazy that's all [ __ ] too
and you know it's [ __ ] just by the
fact that they don't want a certain type
of people to come here to get jobs
I mean if white Americans are so lazy
because they're living off the
government well why wouldn't you want
someone who wants a job to come in here
and get one
I mean you want your [ __ ]
cheeseburgers don't you Jesus Christ we
gotta have [ __ ] cheeseburgers in this
goddamn country I want service and I
want it now
[ __ ] boneheads
boneheads
complete
utter
stunningly stupid
[ __ ] idiots
always on both sides of the fence and
this is this is really the craziest
[ __ ] trap that Trump put us in with
these people is he he kind of trained
them how to straddle the fence you know
you got you know you know what he did
you know how he always said two things
in one [ __ ] he's saying two different
things and one goddamn sentence
two things at the same time and you
always gotta wait two weeks for the
conclusion of what he said
it's always two [ __ ] weeks it's all
success is always two weeks away well I
mean
right now it's till August so we got
till the end of the summer
maybe September 89th I don't know
with these [ __ ] bone-headed people
and by the way
they know that if they do this audit and
overturn the election
and they it's some [ __ ] crazy
nonsense happens where they take Joe
Biden and Kamala Harris out of office
because there was they rigged the
election which is there's no evidence of
we've went through this time and time
and time again there's a almost 70 Court
cases here
and
they understand that if if those results
are nullified the Constitution doesn't
make the last president the president
the Constitution from everything that
you can tell from the Constitution
because this has never happened before
because it probably will never happen
because it's not going to happen this
time because there is no [ __ ] there is
no
oh there is there's there's no fraud
they didn't no one no one stole the
election
but in some [ __ ] alternate universe
where these audits would turn out to
work or whatever the [ __ ] they think is
going to happen
whatever
the [ __ ] they come up with the next
story
if Joe Biden and Kamala Harris somehow
are exited from the White House and from
the office of the presidency and the
vice president Donald Trump the
Constitution doesn't make Donald Trump
the president
the Constitution makes the Speaker of
the House the president
which is Nancy Pelosi and it will be
Nancy Pelosi presumably in August
it'll be a Democrat because they control
the house
right now today if their audit
overturned the election if that's really
what they want
then what they're asking for is Nancy
Pelosi to be the president not Donald
Trump the Constitution that's not what
the Constitution does like it does
things just like just like you [ __ ]
idiots didn't know that on January 6 you
weren't gonna [ __ ] overturn the
government
that was ceremonial the vice president
didn't have that power just like just
like back then when Mike Pence didn't
have the power to overturn the election
by just saying ah I deem Donald Trump
the king of America
just like he didn't have the power back
then to do that and that was a [ __ ]
delusion your deluded thing where Donald
Trump's gonna Ascend to the presidency
because they overturned Joe Biden and
Kamala Harris's uh office It's the
Speaker of the House it's it's right now
it's Nancy Pelosi that would
that would be the president of the
United States and and that president
Nancy would finish the term
and you'd run an election in 2024 but
they would finish the term
and Cindy Powell even said this garbage
she even said this but she missed the
[ __ ] point
she said Donald Trump's gonna be
reinstated they're gonna set a new
inauguration date and that's why she has
to say that they have to set a new
inauguration date because if they don't
set a new inauguration date then he
doesn't become president
but there's nothing in the Constitution
that sets a new inauguration date that's
why she says at the end she she's
untethered from reality and she's free
to say whatever [ __ ] garbage comes
out of her puny Little P brain but then
she ties it back to reality to give it
some sort of Truth and she says well he
would just have to finish out the term
that is that is currently in place until
the next inauguration he would just have
to deal with that because that's what
the Constitution says so she got that
little sliver right
like that one [ __ ] thing now she's
not right about how that would work and
the situation that she's in the delusion
that she's creating it in but that one
sliver that one thing if you pull that
one thing out where if a president we've
had instances where this has happened a
president leaves office
and is no longer the president the vice
president or whoever in the secession
takes over that office
what happens is they fulfill the rest of
that term
because that's how the Constitution
works I mean I'm not saying it's perfect
I'm just saying that's that's the
[ __ ] fact so when she pulls that fact
out to give you that fact then she
couples it with a bunch of nonsense
that's why these people begin to
perpetuate this nonsense even more
it's because they can't figure out
what's true and what's not true on the
internet just like this [ __ ] Magneto
lady
she sees a couple pictures of people
with spoons on their foreheads
and all of a sudden the vaccine makes
you Magneto
maybe maybe I'd want to be Spider-Man
maybe that's what I'd I don't know I
think that'd be pretty cool maybe maybe
not Wolverine maybe I'd
maybe I'd spring for the the the the
Spider-Man
uh upgrade I wonder if they'll have that
I I got I got the modernist so I don't
know if moderna is gonna do the
Spider-Man upgrade or if it's just like
the Magneto
upgrade in the future not real sure but
obviously I'm joking YouTube don't take
my video down because I'm making jokes
they did they took a video down I think
it was episode 12 I believe this is
episode 22. can you believe that it's
been 22 weeks but it was episode 12 I
believe they took down uh because I was
talking about the vaccine I never really
could get it back up because I never
could figure out exactly what I was
saying so I couldn't I I'd have to cut
the whole part out and I was like yeah
[ __ ] it it's it's it lives on the
podcast it lives on Apple podcast and it
lives on Spotify so if you want to
listen to the band uh episode it's
episode 12 you can go download it on
Apple podcast or Spotify it is there it
lives there
um but it doesn't live on YouTube
because YouTube pulled it down because I
said something about the vaccine and I
think what I said I think what I said
was I was making fun of what they say
about it and then that's when they cut
me
and I get no you can't say that I was
like wow I was saying it because I was
saying that it was not true but you know
whatever so instead of cutting the
episode to try to figure out what I said
because they won't they don't tell you
exactly what you said they won't say
these words are the words that we didn't
like
they just say in general why they banned
it and why they banned it is because I
said something that was misinformation
about the vaccine and now I'm saying
these words they may ban this episode so
I don't know maybe check check in the
future to see if Episode 22 is taken off
YouTube I don't know
but it'll be on Spotify it'll be on
Apple podcast because you know they
don't take [ __ ] down over there
and we're on Twitch now did you guys
know that we're on Twitch I don't I
still haven't figured out it's some kind
of streaming gaming software thing or I
again I unlike the Magneto lady when it
comes to Twitch I have no clue I guess
maybe you do have to have 5G or
something to get twitch I don't know I
thought it was for gamers I apparently
there's a lot of podcasters that are
over there they do shows over there
and I thought I knew it was a live
streaming but I did not know that the
videos stay there but they stay there I
don't know if they stay there for a
certain amount of time or if they they
keep going I I don't know so there's
some episodes over on Twitch we're
streaming right now right [ __ ] now
right now like as we speak on Twitch
we're also we also stream on Twitter
because you guys know I love some
[ __ ] Twitter love me love me some
[ __ ] Twitter
and I love all the people over at
Twitter all the people that follow me
and especially especially all the haters
I have some really nice hater followers
over there have you guys noticed that
they all the same ones appear in the
threads it's the same ones all the time
they're my biggest fans really they're
some of my biggest fans but I appreciate
you guys following me on Twitter and on
Tick Tock
um I I I wonder if we can ever stream
live on Tick Tock from the software that
I use I'd like to stream the podcast
live on Tic Tac but yeah Tick Tick Tock
I I stopped doing limes over there
because they they they it's it's tough
because it's all automated moderation so
if someone goes in a room and they're
offended by what you say mainly mainly
Trump bumpers they'll come in and
they'll say ah it's offensive and then
they just shut you off and they ban you
for seven days you have to appeal and
you get your ability to go back in a
couple days and then it's just a process
and it's not really worth it so I really
don't do lives with that I try to live
on Twitter I tried it live on Twitter uh
yesterday I believe I completely [ __ ]
it up I don't know if my my airpods were
not connected properly but here's the
thing I thought about it for a while and
I think here's what I did
so I went to do the live on Twitter and
I had my phone I was trying I couldn't
even figure out how to do live on
Twitter so I was trying to figure out
how to you know manage to get it on live
I finally figured that out
because I Googled it and then and then
when I finally figured out how it was
I'm like oh I need my airpods in
I need those in so I put those in and
they connected but I think because I
already had the live thing up or
something it it [ __ ] up because the
sound was all jacked up and you can go
watch it you can go down in the thread
in my feed and you can see that the live
is there and uh you know you can
you can go ahead and you can watch it
it's not worth it because the [ __ ]
sound is jacked up the sound doesn't
match my mouth you know I'm talking and
it it got [ __ ] up
but anyways so maybe I'll start doing
some some more intimate lives on Twitter
if you guys would like that uh maybe you
guys see a little more behind the scenes
type stuff uh and I appreciate you guys
joining us on the podcast it's every
Wednesday three o'clock Central four
o'clock Eastern
right here on YouTube on Twitter and on
Twitch live
and then what I do is I take the audio
to all you people out there listening on
Apple podcasts and Spotify and all your
other uh podcast directories I take the
audio
and I put that
on the people who just want to listen to
the other because you know you got two
different types of people in the world
you got two different types of people
you got the people who like to watch
podcast and the people who want to
listen to those [ __ ] those are
the two types of people
actually there's three types the people
who don't watch podcasts but who the
[ __ ] wants to even have anything to do
with those people and I can say that
right now on this podcast because they
aren't gonna watch this [ __ ] they don't
watch podcasts they don't listen to
podcasts [ __ ] them [ __ ] em
I should have ended it there but you
know that's how it happens
I appreciate you guys coming here every
week listening to my [ __ ] yelling
screaming to a microphone
follow me on Twitter follow me on Tick
Tock subscribe on YouTube go to Twitch I
don't know again I think you I think you
follow on Twitch I think it's what you
do yeah it's a it's a follow so go
follow me on Twitch
if you're out there and you're listening
on Twitch hit the follow button I guess
again I'm not real sure exactly how that
works yet I don't even know if I'll ever
figure it out but I might I might and if
you guys want to support the podcast
other than just liking and subscribing
and listening and liking and commenting
which I appreciate all that uh
Brandy Brandy she's always on here hi
Brandy
I appreciate you guys commenting and
talking and I try to interact with you
guys on on Twitter as much as I can tick
tock's a little more difficult but I try
to interact with you guys on Twitter
but if you'd like to support the podcast
more than just subscribing we have [ __ ]
them stickers you just go to
thetonymichaels.com that'll help out and
then we got the hacks too you can look
at those and I changed the website up
over there so I did some new things with
the website so go check that out if you
haven't been over there in a while uh
you'll see some new art and it looks a
little different and it looks different
if you look at it on your phone it looks
a little different than on your computer
which you know whatever that means
because it's link tree it's not anything
special it's just link tree and it's got
links on it it's all the stuff the
podcast and the and the store and all
that kind of good stuff so go over there
check that out
follow me on the all the other socials
and uh you know
Brandy says you got yours did you get
your sticker Brandy is that what you got
did you get your sticker your [ __ ] um
sticker how are you at
Everyone likes the I like the [ __ ]
sticker because you can put it
you can stick it anywhere you know
anywhere you want to protest someone
someone posted um on uh on Twitter that
they got their [ __ ] sticker I know uh
I believe Troy got his hats he liked his
hats but you know to give you a little
bit of background I don't know if you
guys have listened to episode one I
think I explained the [ __ ] thing you
got a sticker up thanks Brandy thanks
for getting a sticker thanks for the
support
I they give you a little bit of
background because we got about 10
minutes left here before I got to cut
off I might cut off soon but to give you
a little background on the [ __ ] them and
I think I talk about this on episode one
or episode two so if you want to go
listen to that day you go listen to that
too but
the [ __ ] em is a protest that's how I
see it [ __ ] them
you know they don't want to do this [ __ ]
them and and it works all kinds of
different ways for just about anything
not just social and political issues it
can be just about anything
anything you can say [ __ ] them to and
that's why that's why I think you should
get your sticker so that way wherever
you want to protest you can protest and
all the proceeds that come from that go
to the podcast I get a portion of what
you pay for the sticker it actually is
through uh spring.com I think it's
called
and they they send you the sticker and I
don't ever even touch the stickers they
they send they print them and send them
to you and uh but they're pretty good
quality to stick to stuff
[Music]
and
the portion of it goes goes to the
podcast that you pay for the sticker and
what that helps pay for just to give you
an idea so you know you're just not
throwing money at the wind here it pays
for all the stuff like the streaming
software you see the you see the the
[ __ ] I'm up here and all this stuff down
here you know it pays for all the
software and it pays for the software to
stream to the three different platforms
all at once so it's all the same and
then it automatically records and then
when I go put it on Apple uh podcast and
Spotify and all the directories it helps
pay for those to be published over there
and stay published so you guys can go
back and listen to them and and
re-download them or or don't but a lot
of people like to go back and re-watch
them uh you know I noticed that you guys
download older episodes like I pay to
keep those up so that's what that's for
it's for all the software in the public
and in any equipment that we get I'd
like to get a new microphone what do you
guys think do you guys like the
microphone you think it sounds all right
eh maybe I should get a [ __ ]
different one I don't know
I don't know but that that's what it all
goes towards not getting rich off this
just just trying to talk to his peoples
and I appreciate you coming every week
and listening here at let's talk the
Tony Michaels podcast and come back next
week because I will be here three on
Wednesday three o'clock Central four
o'clock Eastern I'm trying to work on a
guest here
from uh someone over on Twitter
uh he does videos too I'm trying to work
on getting him to be a guest either in
the coming weeks I'm not going to tell
you who it is I want you to guess so uh
so hopefully I'll have another guest
it's been a while since I had a guest
but
until then until next week until
Wednesday at three o'clock Central four
o'clock Eastern
[ __ ] them
[Music]